au collège de cambuston élèves et
professeurs feront de cette semaine pour
la troisième année consécutive la
semaine de la persévérance et c'est dans
ce cadre que le président du département
accompagné d'élus et de conseillers
départementaux est venu encourager les
actions valorisant la persévérance des
élèves et la prévention du décrochage
scolaire sans effort n'y a pas de bons
résultats et la persévérance et cela
c'est justement de les garder à l'esprit
que chaque jour qui passe nous devons
maintenir les efforts soient justement
arrivé à de bons résultats
c'est tout ce que je souhaite à ces
enfants de tous les collèges la réunion
en particulier aux enfants du collège de
cambuston
les représentants politiques ont planté
ici symboliquement deux arbres de la
persévérance endémiques de la réunion un
bois de cannelle et un bois maigre les
collégiens ont choisi aménagé eux mêmes
cet espace baptisé du nom de la marraine
de cette action la place mémona
hintermann à fidji sur chaque balle est
allée lettre de collèges plus tôt et
ceux des galets yade et le nom des
valeurs ou des citations sur les valeurs
importantes de la vie je sais que ce que
ça veut dire la difficulté d'avancer
parce qu'on se dit c'est pas pour moi
mais justement c'est de là vers ce que
je veux dire à ces jeunes c'est pour toi
avance des collégiens engagé au sein de
leur établissement à cambuston
il prône des valeurs de réussite de
développement durable et de vivre
ensemble
[Musique]